welcome to ask gamespot I'm Chris waters
this is sean McGinnis and we're talking
watch dogs today more specifically I'm
asking watch dogs on behalf of you yes
at Sean I'm gonna be answering the
watchdog's question yeah because
unfortunately for you I'm the one who
got to play the game for about four
hours last week you played it from the
very beginning got to check out some
story missions goofed around for a
little while sounds cool so I think I
have a pretty good idea of what watch
dogs is about alright I guess we'll find
out at least here we go if you recognize
this man notify police immediately our
first question is from jawsome art over
Twitter who wonders what sort of moral
choices might we have meaning do we have
any choices that affect the outcome of
the story element so watch dogs is not
it doesn't have those branching
narrative moments like you would find in
a bioware game or bethesda game but i
think what makes watchdogs interesting
from a morality standpoint at least is
the way you have that really immediate
access to people's personal information
and the way that color is your moment to
moment decision making so for example
maybe you're like infiltrating a
security compound and you're about to
pop a bullet into a guy's head and all
of a sudden your profiler tells you he's
a single dad or he volunteers at the
Children's Hospital okay suddenly you
feel like a real piece of garbage about
killing the guy so maybe you just sneak
up and take them out non-lethally
instead on the flip side of that maybe
you see that somebody makes about two
hundred fifty thousand dollars a year
and you suddenly feel less guilty about
robbing their bank account so it kind of
works both ways to with Cassie V 0 0 is
wondering will the hacking interface be
easy to understand or will it get too
complicated because how them of how many
things you can hack in the game so I
mean the funny thing is there's really
not much of an interface to speak of
when you're looking at stuff in the
world that you can hack it's really just
kind of like a subtle white outline on a
security camera or a sewer grate or
whatever other hackable object there is
the one that you can hack right now this
second will have like a prompt on it
that says like press X or square to
okay security camera so it's like it's
immediate it's responsive you hack that
one thing it can get a little finicky
when there's like a ton of things around
you because it all kind of gravitates to
what's in the middle of your screen so
that's the thing that you can hack right
now but I mean as long as you've got a
pretty good command of the camera and
the way that you're you know you're
aiming works it's pretty simple to do
next up it's the fat guy wondering how
did the firearms feel in watch dogs you
get more of a Last of Us bulky feel or
more of a call of duty type vibe smiley
face those are very opposite ends of the
spectrum you know Call of Duty is very
fast and frantic last of us is very
plotting and slow and deliberate I think
watch dogs is somewhere a little bit
more in the middle and in fact the game
that it reminds me a lot of is splinter
cell oh okay you know no surprise
because that's also ubisoft game sure
but a lot of the time you're using these
tech gadgets as well so watch dogs heads
like the sticky noisemaker from Splinter
Cell where you you know you crap this
little device you chuck it in a corner
you active remotely activate it suddenly
it's like chirping and drawing the
attention of a guard over there so that
you can sneak this way think about aiden
is that he can die really fast he's only
gonna take a few bullets before he died
a lot a Kevlar trench coat no that is
not so you're like the thing about watch
dogs is you're not a bullet sponge so
for me the game really encourages
stealth it really encourages using
gadgets I mean you can play it as a
straight-up shooter it's just gonna be a
lot more challenging at least I mean in
my experience with me deluxe wants to
know can you shoot while driving or
shoot well grab that's the chute won't
drive yeah that's how one would shoot
well drive it yeah in watch dogs no I'm
pretty sure that you can't at least not
in my time with the game did I discover
a way to shoot while driving and I tried
you can pack stuff while you're driving
so if you're running away from the cops
you can hack a drawbridge that you just
cross so that it goes up as the cops are
driving into it kind of stopped their
advancement the developers are kind of
trying to know
you in that direction instead of like
the unbridled chaos direction I'm just
popping off a few shots into the air it
seems we've got a lot of curiosity about
the driving mechanics in watch dogs as
trick 2092 wants to know are there radio
stations you can listen to that have
licensed songs there are licensed songs
in the game and a lot of them are
actually like chicago bands there's a
lot of like rise against lawrence arms
alkaline trio a lot of those like local
bands it seems like they're trying to
focus on chicago music there's not like
radio stations that you would find in a
GTA game instead you're basically just
kind of like skipping songs in one giant
playlist okay sometimes you'll hear news
updates on stuff that just happened in
the game but you're not switching
between like a dozen different wildly
different radios does it have the
musical Chicago soundtrack in it as well
I hope so cause Romano's wants to know
how much can we customize aiden is he
fully customizable or is it more like
Assassin's Creed where you have like
preset outfits it's definitely the
second one all right you can there are
clothing shops in the game you can run
in there and say I'm gonna buy a new
coat and the coat come it's like this
pre-made outfit you buy a new coat comes
with a new hat sometimes it comes with
new pants and shoes oh but they're all
you know they're all preset you're not
choosing individual clothing items okay
some of them are really subtle like you
can change from your brown leather
jacket into a black leather jacket huh
some of them are crazy like purple and
like full army digital camo which is
ironically like the least subtle thing
you could wear out in the street chicago
city yeah I know
yeah just two more questions to go and
the first one comes from victoire Gobert
who wants to know is this a game that
sacrifices story for gameplay is the
main character a human with emotions or
a robot so that's actually a really good
question and I think it's something that
a lot of people were thinking looking at
the early gameplay demos and trailers
for watch dogs because aiden pearce as a
character he looks on the surface pretty
cold and unemotional he's a vigilante
he's out for justice vengeance whatever
that means and he's just gonna hack a
whole lot of [ __ ] along the way but
having played the game and seeing how
the story unfolds within the first few
hours I was actually pretty impressed by
the way that they kind of like marry the
themes of hacking with Aiden's
personality so he's a guy who's like
who's grieving who suffered loss and he
has this floor in his life and you know
he feels that with hacking you know he
goes out into the world and he feels
like he is in control of something and
it's I know it's just really interesting
the way that they married those two
ideas in the game you know that's the
first few hours of the game I don't know
where they go from there with the other
characters and how much he evolved as an
urban vigilante he doesn't always do the
right thing and that's pretty clear from
the get-go but he's you know he's trying
he's just a very troubled guy some
things you can't walk away from and our
final question comes from k gadu who
wants to know do you think watch dogs
has a sustainable future as a series
based on what you've seen so far I mean
that's a broad question right because it
could go in any number of different ways
all I know is that I play about four
hours of the game I really enjoyed it
I'm really eager to play the full thing
I you know I can't assign it a final
score and say that this is the greatest
game of this generation there should be
more of these or nor can you comment on
the conclusion and how it sets up
anything that might come to pass exactly
i but i do think that the interesting
question is what is UV saw going to
isolate as the kind of like overarching
themes of watchdogs and how are they
going to apply that to future games so
like in Assassin's Creed it's all these
crazy different historical timelines and
characters but the
narrative thread throughout the whole
series as Templars and assassins and
their conflict together what's that
going to be in watch dogs are they going
to get like super crazy with the hacking
stuff as time goes on or is it going to
be something a little bit more narrative
driven I don't know that's I think
that's going to be kind of the big
question but you know I I really enjoyed
what I played the game so far and I
think it's going to turn out to be a
good one and that'll do it for this
episode of ask gamespot folks thank you
for watching watch dogs of course coming
out in just about a month so we're gonna
have a lot more on it on gamespot in the
coming month and of course once it's a
release so stay tuned for that and
special thanks to Shaun not only for
sharing your wealth of knowledge on the
watchdog's but also for getting through
this without making any terrible dog
related jokes or meme cracks or anything
like that maybe just to hold that
thought you are here
god damn it